welcome to this video round five of the
World Championship match between
defending world champion magnus carlsen
and challenge efficient and we have
reversed roles have compared to 2013
yeah round five yeah unfortunately I
didn't do any coverage of round two
three and four due to my illness break
but I'm going to continue now of course
starting with game five thinking if I
should do something about Game two three
and four as well I'm not sure about it I
mean those have been covered by now and
there's really not that much to add I
guess two things that already have been
said in other videos so I'm just going
to continue with the match as it turned
it was along this some day head round
five let's kick this off I actually have
the position on the bottle ready for
move three year see ya this is in fact
cards deviation from the round three
game we had the same moves at the
beginning but now in Game three cards
and played the Queens gambit declined
with d5 and lost a pretty yeah pretty
drastic game in this line I'm quite to
my amazement because well not knowing
this the specific line when you play
this opening is really really
embarrassing especially for I mean for
any Grand Master even but for a world
champion okay let's not get into that um
in this game today he however played the
move b6 the Queen's indian defence
probably this is some more if you want
to call it like that cartons main
repertoire but he's switching around all
the time to dodge preparation by the
opponent's so it's hard to really assign
any line to master the main line yeah
the Queen xenian what
an unprepared um yeah he played g3 g3 is
the main move in the Queen's Indian
basically since this opening um yeah is
existing for good reason yeah it's
always a good idea to get a counter
fianchetto going if black intends to
fianchetto on b7 and yeah they have been
some recent discoveries in recent years
especially things like Bashar a6 Quincy
to was really revelation that this is a
good line for white one let's say a
promising dangerous line not clear that
it really gives one anything but it's um
it really helped to give wide more
resources in key lines an update cards
until Calvin played now Bishop b4 check
this is not a very common move at this
particular moment the check however is
very common I mean we have openings like
the bogo india near where i'm writing
this book we have bishop before checks
in all shapes and sizes in the Queen's
Indian and Queens gambit complex here's
however pretty uncommon situation to
play it not a bad not a bad situation
mind you but it's not very common bishop
d2 and Bishop back to e7 yeah this is
the idea very often of this check by
provoking Bishop d2 black is in a way
he's losing a movie I could have played
Bishop e7 immediately but his idea is
that this Bishop is not so well placed
on d to in some closed type of positions
on the fianchetto actually is the best
situation for this bishop on b2 would be
the best square so not so easy from d2
and another idea this is less obvious is
that it breaks the support of the Queen
to deform enter d5 so a push d 45 for
example now is less likely to happen
when the queen is not supporting this um
all in all very often this check
it's something that black can consider
our no plate Knight to c3 um Bishop g2
is the main alternative the difference
is that after Bishop g2 here black can
start with a quick c6 and play d5 next
move yeah something like this black get
sufficient control over you for so that
white cannot play for this position in
fact can easily be classified as a
Catalan opening not a Queen's Indian um
it can easily arise from the pure
Catalan move on a d4 Knight f6 e46 g3
Bishop before check um it's a
fundamental decision here for why do you
want to allow black to play d5 thus
preventing e form or do you want to get
in or try to get an e for yourself and I
don't try to get an e for himself 93
Bishop e7 Bishop g2 and now contemplate
the move c6 yeah that's an interesting
way to play it this this whole line is
totally forgotten but it's it's quite a
funny coincidence while you only see a
couple of games in the database if you
look at this I am have some experience
myself because this is a line that I
actually played as black in the mid-90s
it's been ages but I remember that I had
some games with that and back then they
also played a form yeah c6 is basically
saying okay I'm going to play d5 next
move and then it's not so clear that
your knight on c3 and your bishop on d 2
is really well placed you better play
your phone away and white should play
for answer on I did and then d5 this was
blacks idea yeah he sort of gives a wide
the opportunity to put those pawns in
the sender and then with d5 he starts
concrete counter play him yeah back then
when i played this like in 1990
six 1997 this is about this time around
then the main line was see text e5c text
e5e 594 and this have always liked for
black I mean always back then I found it
interesting putting this knight on e4
giving giving it a very nice position
here but on the other hand it is a
position where white enjoys the space
advantage definitely with d4 d5 and
their long-term sometimes even an attack
on the King side as possible of course
the bishop on g2 is not ideal for that
but very often white can regroup it like
that yeah this would have been an
interesting alternative and certainly an
interesting middle game but Allen played
differently it seems that he had um yeah
maybe not anticipated but he had a hit
he it was part of his general
preparation probably not off for this
game but his general preparation he took
with the e porn C take Steve and 95 also
interesting why does by exchanging with
the e pawn on d5 opening up the long
diagonal and he's got some pressure now
on the center c takes see porn denied
the bishop there's lots of pressure
there and in fact the pressure is so
substantial that the next couple of
moves are pretty much forced black
castles there's also Queen a for that he
had to worry about so castling is really
mandatory castles and knight c6 yeah 96
now initiates a long forced sequence it
attacks the default poner note that this
is one one point of the bishop being on
d to where it's a no an attack on d4
yeah what should why do the problem is
for what um or let's say one thing he
has to to look her to look out for is
that in an ER possible um IQ
p position his pieces are not so active
yeah it's very unlikely to get any kings
i play or get d 45 going he should stay
active all the time so something like
let's say taking here and then just take
a year this is just excellent for black
out here the point will get get into
trouble in the long run what has to stay
active and what what Allen played a
thing is is just a good continuation
that keeps a little a little bit of an
advantage for white he took on d5 with
the pawn directly um also there is oops
also there is Bishop f4 that they also
just make make quite some sense but see
if I've is good cards now took on e5
with the night I think this is the best
move taking on d5 with the night which
is also quite quite obvious let's say
might be answered by the capture and
Queen a form and here white enjoys the
slight advantage I'd say yeah it's just
the case where this Bishop is more
active than then this Bishop on b7 and
let's say after capture and white eggs
with the pawn the d5 pawn really might
really might get into trouble in the
long run also this is quite strong 1e5
ya think this is something that black
should avoid so I think his move us
better um council just took on e5 year
95 have interesting yeah and now a very
important moment actually because this
is Sir the case where a quick move that
is not really to the point can lead to
absolutely nothing if wipe now routinely
recaptures after Knight takes d5 and
let's say something like that
we get to a situation where ya whitis is
even slightly very slightly worse okay
you should never lose but this is just
not very nice young this is Bishop
looking at you five um it is it should
be beer draw but it's a very very
unattractive prospect for white this
simple recapture is not really am not
really good so let's go back what to do
instead are now played the most d6
technically a novelty but it's really
the only move that gives what anything
and I understand that it looks very
confusing maybe at first it's something
that maybe you should take a moment of
time to understand yeah why does not
recapturing by putting out d6 and here
we have a situation we are quite funny
enough a like three pieces are hanging
be 5 e 7v seven and very often we as
white we can take things with a temple
um I can't play it basically the only
movie played 96 but just for example if
instead there is something like Bishop
g2 why takes on e seven and then only
five and now it's quite funny it's equal
material but it's a double attack on
Bishop and night so that Bishop everyone
takes takes takes is for stand here we
have a typical situation why it has two
minor pieces against rook and pawn and
here the why the minor pieces have good
positions on c3 the bishop would come to
e3 probably and then something like this
might lead to pressure on the queenside
here white is just better so there are
many ways for black to to lose a
material with bad play what council play
this sound is simply the best
continuation he went 96 and now White
has to get a piece
d7 Queenie 7 yeah and now right now
really only has one continuation it is
very forced now the pony on deform can
easily become weak if white plays slow
moves let's say this movie like we
should be three like we put something
here one of the rooks and all of a
sudden this pressure gets serious and
white cannot easily push the five this
is controlled so he shouldn't play such
a slow move Bishop g5 is by far the best
museum setting up this pin and directly
threatening to push d5 yeah and the next
moves I am pretty much forced age six
you need to get rid of this pin
definitely d5 counter check 9 a-5 yeah
not nice but probably necessary takes
and takes only six very natural Queen
takes rook e1 Queen f6 all this is
fairly natural and an almost forced yeah
what about this situation is it totally
equal not it's not because of this nylon
85 the night only five is really breaks
problem the holds the whole structures
of course totally symmetrical five
against five parts and also um symmetry
in case of the wing distribution like
two against two and three against three
this really points to a draw but there
is one different problem one difficult
at night especially as white now played
95 which is strong yeah here the capture
on be tuned for black is probably not
advisable he can take it but something
like this is a problem the Queen does
not have any squares really can easily
get trapped
something like this is some quite
logical and now white can play something
like that getting two minor pieces for
the rook yeah this is a long line after
Queen takes be too but it is pretty much
force very difficult to to deviate from
that I think Queen takes between plea
not good and what cards played I played
this relatively quickly is better he
took on d5 just heck this night off
Bishop takes rook the 84 pin pin on the
Queen yeah we have a pretty nice
situation here bishop on d5 against the
bed night on a five now black here has
to be very very careful to not fall into
a situation where he's suffering with
the worst minor piece especially
considering that the bishop here on d5
is also looking at some critical
critical pawns and then points like f7
yeah very often this this bishop in
combination to something coming on the
7th will be very very problematic yeah
but let's have a look at this in
concrete terms it is white smooth violin
smooth and I think he played the best
movie played Queen to f3 it is almost
impossible to get do to get anything
going without queena 3 you're in a pin
or you were in a pin on the D file and
you have to make sure this pin is lifted
so queena 3 is strong yeah here's an
interesting moment um because Carlton
now has a fundamental with surgeon and I
really ah it's hard for me to tell him
what is better he decided to capture on
b2 and after that I think he's
definitely suffering a bit but I think
he also suffers in the other
continuation of course the alternative
was to directly trade on a three and now
try to play this position of black
it's still this problem of this night on
a five against the bishop it is if this
night let's say would be on f6 there's
really nothing happening yeah white is
still a little bit better but difficult
difficult to imagine that there's
something happening but with the 9 a-5
hmm yeah I think something like rupee
aid is probably probably necessary and
from here yeah it will come to a
situation where I just want to put the
general structure on the board we have
this straight maybe Luke c 1 and 10 in
group c 7 and then rupee 7 this kind of
situation and again note this night can
only go to be seven know and this is not
fun at all would like to play a
completely understand why accountant
didn't do it i think they asked him in
the press conference and detect that
this type of position is just a torture
to play that's true i think yeah maybe
his his move was better but i'm i'm not
sure it is it is not not really create
in any case we can go back and compare
he took on b2 after which a nine-play
truck 81 yahoo it really one is strong
it intends to play rupee seven it wasn't
possible immediately because the rukon a
one who was just hanging so Brooke 81
prepares his rookie seven move and here
um yeah cookies having us really a
problem I think what causal plate is
right he played Queen f6 getting rid of
Queens at least so that there is some
pressure off yeah I think something like
let's say you play move like that then
rookie seven its and that's not good I
think we Nev success is logical really
yeah this was played aren't exchanged
and played rookie seven yeah now King g7
that's very very normal and here we come
to to an interesting situation
um here and I'm took on a seven which is
not not a bad move here but it is still
interesting if you in this position
maybe should try to keep a little bit
more tension the issue is that after the
capture I can put it on the board
calicut play night I was able to play
knight c6 and get the night back from
the edge of the board an interesting
alternative here was maybe rook to c7
that looks looks at all the critical
squares of the night so that it can
definitely not move and I'm not totally
sure how black should defend now I think
here wyd really has a a nice pressure um
maybe this move attending rook d8
something that white needs to react to
we cannot just play something like that
I mean this is just a check and
afterwards you will loose material so
after route to the six I think white
probably will move the bishop to have
three cakes and now we see here that
black has a hard time to keep any of
response here anyway yeah I note that
that this is still possible and the
night is totally dominated you know
maybe maybe something like this let's
say a six this is not for us but just
what want to put it on the board what
what might happen this kind of thing
yeah black now he has returned a point
but with this situation at least he's
breaking this diagonal look a seven
rooks e5 and here white is just better
yeah he's better and he can continue to
press um if it is enough for win
questionable maybe I'm with perfect
defense blackwell blackwell hold but
it's not much fun I think that rook c7
was maybe if we go back
and that rook c7 was maybe a little bit
tougher but okay Alan's move also
preserves an edge Luke a 796 and yeah
here maybe the second situation where
you could could try to improve what's
clear is that Alan smoothly played rugby
seven that this is a direct role after
rugby seven the game is basically over
but he could have played rook a form
which was interesting trying to switch
over here and I still believe that this
should preserve an edge provide I mean
and it's not much fun to play I think
maybe like this b5 check kingi to we are
and probably we will get something like
this rook to d6 again one trade and then
I mean the position like that it is
clear that black has improved a little
bit because he's not yeah he does not
have to suffer with the rookie on the
seventh from wide or a direct pressure
on f7 but still this is the worst
structure and the bishop is still the
more dangerous p so white can definitely
continue in this position and try to
press I'm very sure that this is the
position that Magnus's wide would love
to play for for ages so I'm not quite
sure why aren't avoided that or what he
did not like about you gay for I still
think that he can press there with very
little risk and I mean very little risk
is so it's putting it mildly white and
risks nothing so I'm a bit surprised
that he didn't do that he just played
rugby seven and now after night before
it is fairly simple the bishop now has
to move and after the trade that a true
porn is directly falling which means a
trait from a against be porn and and
this is now totally equal like we'll get
the night over with f5 he even gets in
94 and here they could have
here they could have agreed to a draw
but they put some more moves on the
board to really get it to a total total
draw yeah and i liked i think didn't
play this anymore but it's a it's of
course debt equal yeah so um an
interesting game that is slightly
mysterious as near the end i think under
without any big yeah there was no risk
involved it's always a question should
he you should you play for win or try
harder to try to win the game it's it's
really a question of risk-taking but
here there is no no risk in playing wuxi
seven or even later with rook affords
even equal material so it's slightly
mysterious why he didn't didn't go for
that i think it was wasn't was a chance
to to exert some more pressure on cars
and sort of torch him a little bit more
with the long game yeah i'm not quite
sure why island didn't didn't do that I
think the initiative in the matches on
his side now anyway after the winner in
round three and trying to push a little
harder maybe once wasn't interesting or
was something to try it's hard to say um
okay the match now continues it
continues tomorrow on the fifteenth with
cards and having wide and then after
rest day cards and again as the white
pieces this little color change in the
middle of the match and those two white
games of course are very important this
is white game three and white game four
and if our nerd manages to to not lose
one of those games I think he's in good
shape yeah in the remaining five games
you will have three whites and with
whitey p got some some pressure here and
he of course he won Game three so can we
be confident down
yeah I hope you enjoyed the coverage for
this game I'll be back tomorrow with
game 6 then we will have the world
champion playing wide and okay maybe
let's see some other Sicilian probably
okay thanks for watching